Qué se sabe de cómo se dio este acuerdo
tan inusual por ser tan prolongado y con
tantos grupos armados
a través de negociaciones mucho gusto
María Clara Feliz año a través de
negociaciones directas con esta
multiplicidad de grupos armados muchos
de ellos grupos envueltos involucrados
en el narcotráfico y en otras formas de
criminalidad organizada ofreciéndoles
por ejemplo abiertamente algunas Y de
forma pública algunos beneficios o en
materia judicial Como por ejemplo la no
extradición a los países que les buscan
a sus líderes Y estos beneficios de los
que usted habla Petro ya lo había
anunciado previamente y ahora afirmó que
La tregua se podría prorrogar Según como
avancen las negociaciones que se sabe de
cómo van los intentos de diálogos con
estos grupos
Pues básicamente se trata de una tregua
que no llega al final de una negociación
después de un acuerdo como ocurrió por
ejemplo con la hoy extinta guerrilla de
las FARC sino que se trata de una
demostración de voluntad de paz y de
voluntad de acogerse y someterse a la
justicia colombiana se sabe poco de
hecho hoy en día no existe en la
legislación colombiana manera de
otorgarle a estos grupos a sus líderes y
a los múltiples combatientes y personas
que están involucradas en ellos los
beneficios que públicamente ha ofrecido
el gobierno que se le van a otorgar a
esas personas y además del eln y las
autodefensas gaitanistas de Colombia
Petro también afirmó que La tregua será
con la segunda marquetalia con el Estado
Mayor central y con las autodefensas de
la Sierra Nevada Cuáles son estos grupos
y Por qué es importante hacer una tregua
también con ellos
son grupos que son derivados del proceso
de paz que terminó con la extinta
guerrilla de las FARC pero también
algunos grupos que te pueden vincular a
aquel proceso de paz de comienzo del
siglo con la que en ese momento se
llamaban autodefensas gaitanistas
unidas grupos paramilitares como los
llamamos aquí en Colombia es importante
involucrar a estos grupos porque
Colombia en los últimos cuatro o cinco
años ha venido transitando por una
multiplicidad de conflictos armados
dejamos atrás los conflictos de la
guerrilla con el estado y de
paramilitares con el estado y ahora
Estamos en una multiplicidad de
conflictos en los cuales estos grupos se
enfrentan entre sí y con el eln Además
del del estado con el eln Y estos
enfrentamientos por supuesto está
dejando a muchos civiles de por medio
como los afrocolombianos los indígenas y
los campesinos y precisamente el
gobierno de Pedro dice que esta tregua
para proteger a estas comunidades qué
tan factible es que esta tregua se
cumpla y se proteja así a los civiles
dado el carácter de multilateral con
todos estos grupos es mucho más factible
que se cumpla recordemos que el eln
había anunciado la guerrilla restante
aquí en Colombia una tregua que el tres
de enero de manera que yo creo que es
bastante factible depende de la
capacidad de la fuerza Pública para
controlar el territorio y de las
organizaciones internacionales como las
Naciones Unidas y de la sociedad civil
en el monitoreo y verificación de esta